do you thing you're here a new graphics
card has come at I had the 1060 Mucha is
ten lower than the last graphics card
yeah and so that makes that leads me to
believe that this is perhaps some sort
of budget card in that same family it's
it's in the same family uses the Pascal
microarchitecture um budget not so much
I would say mid-range okay it's starting
at $250 it the card that I reviewed is
the essentially the reference model of
the founders Edition which is three
hundred dollars right and yeah it's it's
basically the card that a lot of people
will get because it offers really good
performance for 1080p and it's not
outrageously expensive right yeah 250
seems like pretty like you standards
like it's actually like one of the most
popular price ranges right it's yeah
it's weird have that consumer purchasing
sort of stuff goes where they they know
where for people say I mean it did a
nice area cuz if you spend you know too
much money if you spend over five
hundred dollars you get diminishing
returns
yes it's for the people who have you
know disposable income out there and
then if you spend too much it's like
later on down the road you're gonna have
to upgrade or whatever to or you'll want
to but this is sort of in that sweet
spot so we talks a lot last time about
the sort of the pros and cons of going
for the 1080 over the 1070 and it's kind
of impossible talk about these cards
without referring to the rest of the
members of their family so what what is
it about the 1060 like how how much how
close is it to the 1070 how much worth
is it just like throwing in that extra
cup like gosh if you have it to get the
1070 sure so the 1070 is let's see I
wrote this down it is 23% faster okay
then the 1060 but it's also 33% more
expensive right
so the 10sec 1060 is actually a better
deal if you are like most people game at
1080p um you know if you want a game at
that resolution then I'd say go with the
1060 the 1070 is more for like 1440p or
if you want to like sort of dabble in 4k
right what about where does virtual
reality come into this to anything
because I'm you know again I'm kind of
super lame any when it comes to this
like I built my own PC again nine months
ago but I don't keep on top of it old
all the time but it seems to be
people are saying you should get that
extra bit of power if you're going to
try and run virtual our multiple
monitors I guess which is well I mean I
think I've said this before but VR is
very graphically demanding you need to
have it's basically running to you know
1080p panels in a way right uh in in
each eye and then you have to maintain a
really high refresh rate or frame rate
of them like 90 frames per second or
higher consistently if it drops it kind
of makes mix it can make emotions sick
yeah so it's really important to have a
high resolution and high refresh rate
the 1064 $250 can do that and also AMD
also release the card not that long ago
the rx 480 which starts at $200 and I'm
actually going to put together a VR
build like a really affordable VR build
I'm gonna try to get it below $100 that
can do that as well cool I saw Asus was
telling one of their wrong systems built
for VR for like $700 $600 really yeah
super well it may have been like a deal
but there it's certain the discussions
placed on the cost of a vibe yeah yeah
sure but I think I see the discussion
changing around VR pretty soon like in
the near future you know where it's this
cost prohibitive thing and that's going
to kind of go away and people are just
gonna be buying pcs it like yeah like
this is VR just works on my PC right I
didn't buy it for VR like it's really
powerful enough out of the gate
yeah I'm looking forward to that because
I think that's the sort of thing that's
gonna make devs
more inspired to actually treat VR like
a worthwhile pursuit yeah right that is
if it's not like it's not like to get a
VR PC it's like this magical sort of
acquirement like if you have a like a
high-end gaming PC that's gonna be able
to do a totally yeah but for a lot of
people I think they're they're maybe
they're not gaming like like a hardcore
gamer yeah and they're just like what
everybody's VR thing what do I need to
do it oh that's too expensive like it's
it's that type of thing where you're
like you you budget for the 600 or $800
thing and then you're like oh but I also
like need to upgrade my grabbers got
like I used to get that a lot when I
worked in retail which is like people
will come in I'm wanted to buy a game
for their kid and then you'd be like oh
but your system requirements are this
and they'd be like ah there's no point
then I'll just get them this other thing
like or you know they wanted to get them
the new console and then realize it
the games cost way more because they're
all new games like there's always that
once you add that like extra cost on to
people that it sometimes becomes that
extra barrier that just kind of stops
them from doing it right yeah yeah so I
should be producing I guess and yeah I
mean it seems like a pretty good one I'm
guessing like what what was the game
which you started to struggle at for you
was it cuz I I see when you're
benchmarks there's all like the good
touchstones of you know those crazy
Eastern European first-person shooters
I was shocking finish all that sort of
stuff so games like like you know
BioShock Infinite shadow of Mordor those
games are sort of what I would consider
like mid-range graphics kind of games
like they're gonna look pretty they're
gonna run pretty well or well optimized
games that will really push your system
include Metro last light right um and
like rise of the Tomb Raider um yeah I
mean like The Witcher to some extent to
a lesser extent but yeah I'll test out a
bunch of different games so like
BioShock Infinite will be like here's a
game that's not super easy to run but
like it will run on like you know it
should be a bit slick a moderate game
and then like Metro last light will be
like here's the final test like where I
can do this one that he can do this
resolution have you thought about
introducing doom into that I'm seeing a
lot of people talking about how I didn't
vote at the Pelican I think Peter was
complained in my reviews too long so I
want to add more benchmarks early look
at you in the future is there such a
thing as too long for Hardware of you I
feel like the people who were my reviews
I reviews are really they are hard it
was like 4,000 workers so it's like
reviewers like how come you don't have
more benchmarks and I'm like this is
already ridiculous and then not only
that I have to go and like test like
five other cards like run all those
benchmarks to of course and then like a
lot of people don't know like I have
sometimes I have like three days or
whatever like a week to do these and I
don't have time to like wearing
benchmarks like takes time oh yeah it
seems simple right just go to the MIT
for some games just go to the menu hit
benchmark but it's a pain in the ass
yeah and I'm like yeah yeah I'm also
doing like experiential benchmarks where
I'm like I'm literally playing the games
I'm like running fraps and recording
average right yeah it's like that right
it's very it's very time intensive and
last question on 1060 sli yes so SLI is
not supported wise
very this is you know it's a bit of a
shame for a cry because anything all you
could run an SLI setup for 500 quid like
that'd be pretty cool yeah so um
so in general I wouldn't recommend most
people go out and buy SLI system you
know I generally recommend people buy
one powerful graphics card over two
because with SLI you have performance
scaling issues like some games don't
even support SLI some games will run
worse on that slide righteous essence
creed one of the Assassin's Creed ones
had that issue having said that though
you know some games do support it and
it's nice to have the option you know
especially later on down the road like
let's say year or two from now intense
sixties really cheap you'd want to like
just get another one for cheap and then
at an SLI get like near double
performance in some games but with 1060
yeah it doesn't support SLI which was
very surprising to me I asked Nvidia why
and they said that it's not very common
in mid-range GPUs and that they're sort
of relegating that to the 1070 and 1080
changes where it's more common do you
think that we're I don't say past SLI
but do you think SLI will sort of
continue to exist or have we reached a
sort of you know we've we've jumped up
so good at you're always going to get
our if they're always gonna move videos
always gonna be more power
people always gonna want better graphics
I think next generation consoles are
always gonna come kind of thing um so
it's yeah I think we're always gonna
want more power I was actually
interviewing teams we need the other
week and I asked him like how many
teraflops would we need to reach
photorealistic graphics and he said he
thinks around forty teraflops and forty
forty ok tariff the 1080 is like nine
teraflops and the new xbox is like six
right so like sort of gives you the idea
like we're far away from like achieving
realistic graphics there you go a lot
more work to be done Jimmy thank you so
much for coming in at ten six your full
review is on GameSpot calm if you want
all those hot benchmark stats head over
to the side and I'll check it
now